une troisième cher à l'estaca comprenait
un enseignement dédié aux enjeux du
véhicule autonome et penser en
partenariat avec des industriels
ce véhicule va être connecté
avec des nouvelles technologies qui sont
émergentes et qui sont encore récente
et donc il faut pouvoir accompagner la
montée en compétences des salariés en
entreprise sur des thématiques qui sont
nouvelles comme la y'at-il eu guttata la
cybersécurité l'aide à la décision
un partage d'expertisé de besoin de
partenaires majeurs sont associés à
cette chère à meuh non
cinquante mille euros par an deux
entreprises du territoire yvelinois le
groupe bertrand installé à vélizy
villacoublay et le groupe renault basé à
guyancourt associés aux compétences
existantes puisque la physique ne change
pas donc associé compétences existantes
il s'agit de développer d'autres outils
d'autres méthodes qui permettent d'aller
à dresser les capteurs la défense
artificiel pour les intégrer et c'est
donc si on additionne donc en addition
de ce qui existe déjà et donc c'est une
chair qui est qui vient dans le
programme global qui viennent enrichir
le programme global la chaire va
permettre de financer l'ingénierie de
cette formation
renous n'est évidemment pas le seul
contributeur tous ceux qui vont ensuite
envoyé des genres en formation son
partenaire de la chaire et vont
collaborer ainsi la formation se déroule
sur trois années où en modules de
formation continue l'estaca vise une
vingtaine de salariés formés par année
en septembre 2021 cette chaire s'ouvrira
à l'apprentissage pour 48 élèves